trailer Matt wall show Donald Trump was
officially arrested and arraigned on 34
criminal charges in New York yesterday
yet even after arresting Trump the
Manhattan D.A still has not explained
what crime he committed that's because
there is no crime at all this is not
about Prosecuting a crime it's about
punishing a political dissident we'll
talk about that today also the people of
Chicago through Lori Lightfoot out and
have now chosen to replace her with
someone who is even worse in every way
plus I had an interesting exchange with
a trans EMT during the Q a portion of my
speech in New Mexico last night we'll
play the clip for it you don't want to
miss that and new polling shows that 60
of Americans agree that Trump should
have been indicted even though none of
them knew what he was being indicted for
in our daily cancellation a new law in
Canada would make it a crime to protest
drag queen events involving children I
have a lot to say about that as you can
imagine and much more today on the Matt
Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign 's plans to help struggling
business owners in the wake of coveted
lockdowns were to prioritize black
latino Native American and women-owned
businesses it goes without saying that
if Biden had said his plans were to
prioritize white male loan businesses
well there would have been outrage so if
you own a business you can't rely on the
government to bail you out uh no matter
what demographic group you belong on
belong to you need to take matters into
your own hands and Innovation refunds
can help you do just that if your
business has five or more employees and
managed to survive covet you could be
eligible to receive a payroll tax rebate
of up to twenty six thousand dollars per
employee through the employee retention
credit all you got to do is go to
getrefunds.com Innovation refunds has
already helped clients claim over three
billion dollars in payroll tax refunds
through the ERC and they may be able to
help your business too this is not a
loan there's no payback it's a refund on
your taxes there's no upfront charge
either so don't let this opportunity
pass you by see if your business
qualifies for ERC assistance in just
eight minutes go to getrefunds.com click
on qualify me and answer a few questions
the payroll tax refund is only available
for a limit time so don't miss out go to
getrefunds.com that's getrefunds.com
it's finally official yesterday in one
of the most disgraceful and alarming
scenes in the history of American
politics former president and current
GOP Primary front-runner Donald Trump
was arrested and reigned on 34 felony
counts in New York no president has ever
been charged with a crime and that's
certainly not because no president has
ever committed a crime in the past
indeed crime and Corruption have been
the norm in D.C and among our political
Elites and yet very few of them and
nobody at Trump's level at the
presidential level have ever been made
to answer for it
except Donald Trump now as I've said
before you know the treatment of Donald
Trump wouldn't be nearly so disturbing
to me personally if we lived in an
alternate universe where politicians are
so despised and so scrutinized that we
always look for any excuse to charge
them with crimes I mean imagine a
Bizarro World version of the United
States where former presidents are
constantly getting handcuffed and tossed
behind bars where that's like the uh
that's the going away president for a
president is that we end up arresting
you for something and high-ranking
politicians are made to live in constant
fear that maybe they cross the line
somewhere they're going to be prosecuted
um that sort of world that sort of
country I think would be very good and I
would enjoy it but that's not the
country we live in in our reality the
political Elites are effectively Above
the Law they're so Above the Law in fact
that's um
just as one example Global you know a
global sex trafficking pedophile can be
arrested and then can quote unquote
commit suicide Big Air quotes around
that in prison leaving behind a detailed
Leisure of every
prominent figure and politician he ever
uh you know sold in underage prostitute
to
and none of them are ever charged with a
single crime in fact the names of the
people in The Ledger are never released
to the public there is no accountability
at all that is how firmly Above the Law
these people are
except Donald Trump
in his case they've spent years and
years pouring through his personal life
rifling through every document they can
find checking his financial records
scrutinizing every jot and Tittle until
they found something to charge him with
but the only problem is that they
actually didn't find anything to charge
him with there's actually nothing there
it turns out that Donald Trump is
perhaps the least corrupt politician in
American history and we know that
because he's one of the only ones that
they've that the system has tried to
find something else try to destroy and
they haven't been able to do it
it was clear from the time that the
indictment was announced that the
Manhattan D.A Alvin Bragg had nothing on
Donald Trump uh he was firing blanks the
whole time yet the indictment itself
remained sealed and up until yesterday
which left open the theoretical
possibility a possibility that the media
clung onto with desperate hope
that maybe there would be some major
Bombshells some big surprise that Bragg
hadn't yet revealed publicly maybe he
was only pretending that this was a
criminal case centering around Trump
paying off some porn star so that she
wouldn't go blabbing publicly about an
affair during a presidential election
which definitely is not a crime
um and and maybe in reality buried in
the indictment would be the Revelation
that Trump also
killed someone maybe he really did shoot
somebody on Fifth Avenue maybe that was
a confession maybe maybe he organized a
bank heist or something who knows that
was the hope that the left tried to
cling to but all hopes were dashed
yesterday as Trump was arraigned and the
indictment was finally unsealed and the
truth was revealed this case really is
as frivolous and insane as we all
suspected and as we all knew they have
nothing on Trump they have no crime now
I'm not a lawyer I admit okay I'm not a
legal expert but based on my limited
legal understanding I'm pretty sure that
the whole point of an indictment is to
lay out a formal accusation of a crime
that that's what that's what indictment
is it's to outline and describe the
crimes that were allegedly committed
but this indictment this historic
indictment of a foreign president leaves
out that part it is an indictment that
forgets to actually indict
the document does not explain what the
underlying crime actually is and to top
it off the statute of limit of
limitations has already passed and to
top that off Bragg is apparently trying
to prosecute a violation of federal law
though again we don't really know which
law
but but even if a federal law was
violated brag as the D.A of Manhattan
likely has no jurisdiction to enforce it
in the first place so
there is no crime but if there was a
crime he can't even prosecute it that
would fall to Federal prosecutors but
they already passed on this case because
they couldn't find a crime to prosecute
either
now you may ask if there's no underlying
crime
how does this indictment have 34 counts
how can Trump be indicted on 34 counts
of nothing
Andrew McCarthy the National Review
explains uh in a piece that was just
published I'll read a little bit of it
it says Bragg's indictment fails to
State a crime not once but 34 times on
that ground alone the case should be
dismissed before one ever gets to the
fact that the statute of limitations has
elapsed and Bragg has no jurisdiction to
enforce federal law if that's what he's
trying to do which remains murky Braggs
and Diamond charges 34 counts just as we
said it would based on media reporting
that clearly came from illegal leaks of
grand jury information a crime you could
be sure that goes in the overflowing
bucket of serious offenses that Bragg
refuses to prosecute the 34 counts are
arrived at by taking what is a single
course of conduct and absurdly slicing
it into Parts each one of which is
charged as a separate felony carrying
its own potential four-year prison term
Trump reimbursed Michael Cohen in
monthly installments during 2017 for the
130 000 paid to porn star Stormy Daniels
right before the 2016 election uh for
her Silence about alleged Affair that in
reality is a single transaction Trump
paying back a debt to Cohen
yet because Trump paid in his
installments and each installment
includes an invoice from Cohen a
bookkeeping entry by the Trump
organization and a payment to Cohen by
check Bragg not only charges each
monthly installment separately he
subdivides the installments into
installments as if the invoice book
entry and check were independent
criminal events voila one transaction
becomes 34 felonies
okay this is not even weak sauce there's
no sauce here this is also you know um
if a prosecutor is confident that
there's a crime here and he's got a slam
dug case he he's he's not going to
um feel that he that he needs to you
know
take one crime and separate it into 34
chunks that's that's the kind of thing
you do when you know you don't have
anything
and so you're throwing everything at the
wall that you possibly can
there's not anything here but a dumb
pudgy self-promoting district attorney
who will tear the country apart uh just
to make a name for himself and on that
score he's already succeeded he has
certainly nationally recognized now
except that he's recognized as a
National Disgrace
I mean this case is such a joke that you
can even turn on CNN to hear detailed
criticisms of it so just as one example
here's John Bolton not a trump fan to
put it mildly on a CNN panel explaining
why the indictment distresses him listen
big picture what do you think of the
indictment well speaking is someone who
very strongly does not want Donald Trump
to get the Republican Presidential
nomination I'm extraordinarily
distressed by this document I think this
is even weaker than I feared it would be
uh and I I think uh it's it's easily
subject to being dismissed or a quick
acquittal for Trump just speaking going
back to the days when I represented Jim
Buckley and Gene McCarthy and the
Constitutional challenge to the
underlying federal statute here passed
in 1974. I can say there is no basis in
the statutory language to say that
Trump's Behavior forms either a
contribution or an expenditure under
federal law the two key definitions at
issue here if it did it would mean that
every single expenditure candidate made
could be taken to have something to do
with his campaign do I buy a one dollar
comb Tacoma hair 10 comb to comb my hair
if if you can construe the statute to
cover this Behavior then I think it
violates the First Amendment because
you're deeply into territory that that
makes this statute absolutely federal
statute too vague for enforcement and as
what I understood the district attorney
to say that he thinks there's a New York
election law involved here all I can say
is the federal election campaign act
absolutely preempts any state or local
law to the contrary how could it be
otherwise you've got one law governing
Corporate Finance in a presidential
election at the federal level you're
going to have 50 state laws interfering
with it so he's just wrong on the
applicability of the New York statute
he thinks he thinks there's a New York
election law that he can use to
prosecute Trump even by the most
generous possible reading here Bragg is
searching for a law that Trump might
have broken he thinks there might be one
he's still not sure but he arrested the
former president anyway
that's the best possible interpretation
and it's far too generous because in
truth Bragg knows that there's nothing
here which is why he couldn't explain
the crime in the press conference that
he held after the arraignment listen to
this
why did Donald Trump repeatedly make
these false statements
the evidence will show that he did so to
cover up crimes relating to the 2016
election
Donald Trump
Executives at the Publishing Company
American Media Incorporated
Mr Cohen and others agreed in 2015 to a
catch and kill scheme that is a scheme
to buy and suppress negative information
to help Mr Trump's chance of winning the
election
as part of this scheme
Donald Trump and others made three
payments to people who claim to have
negative information about Mr Trump
to make these payments they set up shell
companies
and they made yet more false statements
oh dear God I mean never mind I take it
all back right forget everything I said
before you mean to tell me that Trump
tried to suppress negative information
about himself during a political
campaign you mean that as part of his
efforts to get elected to public office
he tried to prevent embarrassing things
from being publicized about him
I mean well surely he's the first
political candidate in the history of
the country to ever do something like
that I mean it's not like literally
every political campaign in the entire
history of politics has also made
efforts to suppress negative information
it's not like that's like an essential
part of campaigning that's part of what
campaigning is no certainly not Trump is
the first to ever do it
that much we can agree on
but still what is the crime
okay is that a catch and kill scheme to
buy negative stories purchase the rights
to negative stories negative information
and then kill it is that is their cry
what's the crime there is there a legal
statute somewhere that says you can't do
that
is it a crime to try and win an election
what's the actual crime well Bragg never
explained but he did say this listen
34 false statements
made to cover up other crimes
these are felony crimes in New York
state
no matter who you are
we cannot and will not normalize serious
criminal conduct
the defendant repeatedly made false
statements on New York business records
he also caused others to make false
statements
well that's exactly the Crux of it
because it says well he's on he's
covering up an underlying crime and but
what is the underlying crime what is he
covering up
and somehow that has not still not been
explained okay so Trump has been
arrested and charged with doing
something to cover up some underlying
crime and no one has explained what that
crime is
but Bragg says we're not going to
normalize criminal conduct
well but except that's exactly
what Alvin Bragg wants to do that is his
entire Mission and it's the mission of
every Soros Goblin D.A
there is no better way to summarize
their strategy than that they want to
normalize crime and they've succeeded
crime has risen sharply since Bragg took
office and was already on the rise
before he took office so it's it's even
worse than it was it was bad before now
it's worse than that
um Bragg is doing everything in his
power to make sure that violent
predators are released back out into the
community as quickly as possible as with
light and with light as light punishment
as possible
um so that he can spend all his energy
trying to punish an innocent man
he is very much making crime normal
that's exactly what these people want to
do
but it's in fact
as we talked about recently
you know they will tell you directly
that this is well it's a normal part of
living in the city
what was it that Seth Rogen said getting
carjacked it's not just big city life
it's normal
this is the way the system works we live
under a regime that will punish the
innocent harsher than the guilty because
the guilty the actual criminals are not
a threat to the system far from it
violent criminals are useful to the
system because they terrorize and
demoralize the citizenry and they break
their spirits and render them bewildered
and vulnerable just as the elites want
and need them to be besides violent
criminals mostly kill and Rob middle and
lower class people whose lives have no
value to the elites
okay criminals are are going after
random commuters on the subway they're
going after people that work in uh gas
stations and convenience stores
well Alvin Bragg doesn't care about them
the political Elites don't care about
them
but Trump committed the real crime
by offending and defying the elites
themselves and that's why they want to
take them down
I said earlier that
trying to win an election isn't a crime
but actually it is as far as they're
concerned that in fact is the crime he's
being indicted for
that he tried to win an election and he
won it
if you're not on their team and you try
to gain political power you have
committed the ultimate crime of defying
them
and that is actually what they want to
make Trump pay for
now let's get to our five headlines
Pure Talk is the antidote to woke
wireless companies it's proudly
veteran-owned employs a us-based
customer service team and absolutely
refuses to spend money on fake news
networks here's a look at what a future
without Pure Talk would look like for
you for those of you who can't see
what's playing out on the screen right
now I am currently texting with my
producer Sean on a phone that's serviced
by one of the big three wireless
networks Sean says have you seen the
post about the left trying to cancel you
again which I reply in this very real
conversation they're always trying to
silence me and it's never going to work
because that's the kind of thing that I
would say in a text message you know in
real life I would text that to someone
when are people going to accept that men
or men and women are women only
autocorrect changes men to MXN and women
to
w-o-m-xn if you can believe it this is
what you get with Welk Wireless
Uninvited lessons in political
correctness if there's anyone I trust to
not only give me the best service for my
money but also not to try to force their
Politics on me it's pure talk no
contracts no hassle and they respect
your politics right now you can get
unlimited talk text and plenty of 5G
data for just thirty dollars a month
keep your phone keep your number or
choose from the latest iPhones on
Androids go to puretalk.com enter promo
code Walsh to save an additional 50 off
your first month that's puretalk.com
promo code Walsh puretalk is simply
smarter Wireless
we begin with the uh
Chicago Mayoral race where Brandon
Johnson defeated Paul Valas and became
the next mayor of Chicago after Lori
Lightfoot got the boot now um there
there were no conservative Republicans
who had any chance of becoming the mayor
of Chicago obviously that wasn't in the
card cards but uh Paul Ballas was a
relatively moderate Democrat but by you
know current day standards a moderate
Democrat which to be a modern Democrat
still means that you're far left but
um
you know he he's he's still he's the guy
that the residents of Chicago would have
chosen if they had learned any lessons
at all from Lori lightfoot's disastrous
tenure so he would have been an
improvement over her anyway and that
would show that the people in Chicago a
little bit slow in the uptake but
they're finally starting to learn a few
things
uh turns out though they learn no
lessons at all or they learned all the
wrong ones
because instead they went with a far
left radical Luna lunatic somebody to
the left of Lori lifeford so take all
the bad things about Lori Lightfoot who
they kicked out they don't want her all
the bad things about her
um this guy
is worse than that
so he takes all those bad things and
makes them worse
this is someone Brandon Johnson who's
called for defunding the police someone
who defended the BLM looters someone who
uh who ran an explicitly racialized
anti-white campaign
so to show you what I mean here's an
article in the guardian from just a few
days ago before the election this is
what it says
Miranda Johnson who now serves as a Cook
County Commissioner has joked in the
past that he didn't become a pastor like
his father or sister because they
weren't unionized but it's clear that
his family's work in the church has
shaped his commanding presence in
secular spaces as it did on the day that
they were profiling Johnson
quoting Johnson now
this is about black labor versus white
wealth that's what this battle is about
Johnson said this is about providing
communities access to the very public
accommodations which black people fought
for especially after emancipation it's
what this the descendants of slaves in
this room are fighting for public
education public transportation
affordable housing health care and
access to jobs
so he framed his campaign
as a battle
uh a a battle between black and white
and he won
okay so if you're a white person in
Chicago and you choose to still live
there well that's on you the guy elected
said this is a battle of black versus
white
and the voters lined up to vote for
in fact it's on everyone in Chicago
if you choose to still live there
because because here's the thing the
people of this city the absolute
self-destructive morons who live in
Chicago
they chose to elect someone who is who
is worse than the mayor that they threw
out
they are choosing to live then amid
crime and violence and chaos and tyranny
this is what they want
they want racial division violence crime
and filth that's what they want to live
in uh they want it so what else can we
do except just let them have it
and feel no sympathy for them this is
what you want you can have you know all
the all the um
hand ringing that a lot of us do about
the violence in Chicago we should you
know and oftentimes we accuse the media
of ignoring the violence in Chicago and
they do
but you know we should just ignore it
too now because that that's it's your
problem you want this you ask you are
literally asking for it
I mean the the very people who are many
of them victimized by the violence in
Chicago they're lining up to vote for
people who promise more of it
who want less law enforcement who want
less Law and Order and they are saying
it
and then these these
idiots
are lining up and voting for that
this is what you want I mean at a
certain point we can't save people we
literally we can't save them from
themselves
and this is the hardest thing to uh
this is one of the hardest realities you
know to accept really
in modern political life
it's that
the problems start with the voters
okay so we can we can um
talk about the corrupt Elites and the
Soros DA's and all that stuff
as as I just did we do all the time on
this show
but it's also true that we still do live
under a democratic system
which which means that you know this guy
is the mayor of Chicago because people
voted for him
no if if they had if they had
overwhelmingly if they had really
overwhelmingly rejected everything this
guy stands for
he wouldn't be the mayor of Chicago
right now
people are getting what they asked for
there's something deeply wrong with many
of the voters many of the people
who are voting for this stuff
and uh
it's at a point it's been a point for a
long time where there's nothing for us
to do except say you can have it and so
yeah if you're a if you're a sane person
if you're a person in Chicago and you
value your own life and you care about
your children and all of that then you
just got to get out give up on it let it
let it fall apart
that I think that's our only path now
all right I spoke at uh New Mexico State
University yesterday it was actually a
great event
um a lot of fun I thought and for the
first time in a long time I was directly
challenged in the Q a by uh by several
people including several trans people
so this happens every once in a while
somebody will get up during the Q a and
they'll try to challenge me on this
issue but this is this is the first time
in a while where
um you know most of the Q a consisted of
people on the other side stepping up one
after another to try to you know debunk
my points or challenge me and which I
which I think is is great it makes it a
lot more fun and uh this is also this is
this is mainly what the Q a is supposed
to be for that's why we have you know
the policy and the Q and A's of these
college events where if you disagree you
get to go to the front of the line
um because that's I mean it's great to
hear from people who are supporters and
they agree they can ask really
interesting interesting questions
but very often then I'm just in a spot
of of restating a lot of things I
already said in the talk
um
it's more interesting to hear from
people on the side so that that happened
here and I appreciated that it's worth
going to yaf's YouTube page to watch uh
the whole event and I think um but I
want to play one Clips kind of lost by
five minutes but it's interesting
because this is a trans person uh one of
a of a few that got it during the Q a
who Begins by presenting his credentials
as an EMT so he's a says he's a medical
professional he's trans
um so he's a you know an authority on
this whereas I am not he says
and you know the back and forth went on
for long enough I probably went on for
about 10 minutes but we'll pick this up
about halfway through
um listen
how would you define a woman because
you've asked other uh people up here to
Define how we would Define a woman how
would you define a woman Mr Walsh uh an
adult human female
[Applause]
and how don't trans people how doesn't a
transgender woman fit that definition
because they're not
they're not female they they have they
have
you said that you are a biological male
correct I said I'm transgender
um I might be in her sex for all we know
about almost as many people in the world
are transgender as intersex and well a
lot of people don't know
all right but that's a different
conversation intersex that's a genetic
anomaly that's a medical condition so
that that's a completely different
conversation it's also not a that's not
a third gender that's just a that's a
genetic anomaly that occurs within the
sex binary of male and female
um
a
so what you're saying is that a
quote-unquote trans woman is a female
by the definitions I'm familiar with yes
so how would you define female
through my training
in health care there are several
different categories for how we Define
sex people bring up chromosomes people
also bring up hormone levels people
bring up all sorts of other categories
lots of people don't fit neatly into a
gender binary even people we don't
consider to be intersex
it's a complicated Spectrum
it's not complicated but you also didn't
you also didn't Define so what is
what is a woman what is a female what do
these words mean
it's complicated and I know you're not
going to like that answer but that's
because there are no simple answers in
human biology
just let me finish
you guys like to bring up
High School level biology classes a lot
I get that a lot but people who go on to
more complicated biology classes we'll
talk about sex as a spectrum it's not
it's not well biological researchers
would disagree with you well and they're
full of the ones that would say that
there's
all right
there are male gametes and female
gametes oh I had one I had one last
question
I I said one I have one quick can you
come back for one second because this is
an important question you said you're an
EMT
okay if you're responding
you're responding to a health emergency
biological mail
somebody with a penis is uh is having a
medical emergency and they say to you
um I think I'm having a miscarriage
would you would you check them to see if
they're having a biscuit would you
consider that a possibility for them
no but
that's because some people don't have
body parts
doesn't mean they're not a woman okay
sounds like we've established there are
some people who in principle can get
pregnant
and there are some people who can't
so there's two categories otherwise
known as binary lots of women can't get
pregnant either
yeah but they're still of the nature to
get pregnant the only reason you can't
get pregnant yes but truth matters right
it does that's what I'm trying to
explain to you
truth matters and they can't get
pregnant that's the truth so how are
they still a woman
because they are
for for this for the same reason for the
for the same reason that I that I can
rightly say that human beings have two
legs and if a person is born with only
one leg that doesn't call into question
the statement that human beings have two
legs okay a person being born with one
leg doesn't mean that now legs are on a
spectrum and we can't say
we can't say anything at all about how
many legs a person has who knows they
could have they could be a centipede you
know they could have they could have a
hundred likes
no we know human beings have two legs if
a human is born without two legs
something went wrong they were supposed
to have that second leg something went
wrong if you if you if you meet a person
on the street only has one leg maybe
maybe they had an accident maybe they
were in war maybe maybe some you know
maybe they were in a car accident maybe
they had cancer a leg was cut off but
you know that something went wrong
because of the by their nature they're
supposed to have two legs same thing for
a woman a woman by her nature can get
pregnant a man by his nature never can
so if you meet a woman of child-bearing
age saying she's 28 years old and she
can't get pregnant you know
automatically that something has gone
wrong and she can go to the doctor and
find out what that thing is even if they
can't fix it so that proves that women
by their nature can get pregnant because
the simple fact that she can't shows you
that there is something wrong this is
what is known as the exception that
proves the rule whereas if a male with a
penis can't get pregnant no doctor on
Earth is going to run tests to see
what's wrong with him
because they already know it's that he's
a male and there's only male and female
those who get pregnant those who can't
so
that's
there it is it it turns out now
when you can be stumped on a rebuttal
like this or a question like this
you know a man of a man somebody with a
penis says I'm having a miscarriage
would would you take that claim
seriously would you actually run tests
to see if that was really happening
and uh and you you could tell that this
was somehow for this person this is
something that they'd never he never
really thought about
but he realized he had to admit well of
course I wouldn't
because there are
two categories of people there are
people who can
get pregnant they're people who can't
they're people who as I try to explain
there people who buy their nature can
get pregnant people who by their nature
cannot those are the two categories
and you could call those categories
whatever you want you know we say man
and woman in the English language uh in
other languages they use other words so
the actual words themselves are words
are simply symbols that stand for
something they're verbal symbols
and so it's true that the verbal symbols
can change they change over time they
change depending on your language
but the reality that they are
symbolizing the reality they represent
that doesn't change
there are people get pregnant people
again
you know as I was trying to explain
there the way the way I phrase it is you
know women by their nature can get
pregnant and I think that that's a a
technically scientifically you know a
precise way of putting it
maybe another way to put it may we say
by their nature maybe for some people it
goes a little bit over their head it
seemed to a bit with the person I was
talking to there
um so another way of putting it is a
woman is someone who is supposed to be
able to get pregnant
a woman is someone who's supposed to be
a man is someone who
is not supposed to be able to get
pregnant and can't
woman is supposed to be able to get
pregnant a man never can so those are
the two
things and then and then that
that means that the uh the comeback of
what about women who can't get pregnant
yeah but they're supposed to be able to
even if they can't they're supposed to
be able to
which is why as I explained there
a woman in childbearing of you know in
childbearing age say a 28 year old woman
can't get pregnant go to the doctor says
I'm not able to get pregnant the doctor
is never going to say well
yeah you're not supposed to be able to
get pregnant
you know you you just belong to a
different category a person who doesn't
get pregnant so we're not gonna run any
tests at all
no the doctor's going to know okay well
that's that's not how that's supposed to
work you're a woman so you should be
able to get pregnant let's figure out
what's going on
and they will they will always find it
you know that's the incredible thing the
doctor will know just based on the fact
that this is a woman
childbearing age can't get pregnant he
will automatically know there's some
kind of medical problem Happening Here
and they will be able to find it
whether they can correct it or not they
can find it there
two categories that's what we call a
binary
all right
um The Daily wire has this report a new
uh CNN poll found that more than half of
all Americans approve of Manhattan
district attorney Oliver bracket
decision to indict for president Donald
Trump
despite the fact that no one surveyed
knew the contents of the still sealed
indictment when they answered questions
about it CNN anchor Jake Tapper uh broke
down some of the results of the poll
which was taken between March 31st and
April 1st it showed that overwhelming
majority of Democrats 94 were in favor
of the indictment majority of
Independents also supported 62 followed
by just 21 of Republicans overall nearly
two-thirds sixty percent of those
surveyed said they supported the
decision to indict Trump
but as quick critics quickly pointed out
neither uh those asking the questions
nor those answering it had any idea what
specific crimes the former president was
actually being charged with
and yet they answered it anyway
so 60 overall so they support the
indictment uh 62 percent of Independence
you know I think that 21 of Republicans
is the biggest concern
for Donald Trump anyway
um maybe not in the primaries but in the
general election
and and we know that that they said they
support the indictment without without
knowing what the indictment is and now
the indictment's been unsealed we still
don't know what the indictment is we
still don't know what the underlying
crime is
except that it doesn't exist we know
that
all that means obviously is that 60
percent
who were polled don't like Trump
that's all like every poll having to do
with Donald Trump
oh do you do you support this thing
that's happening to Trump or do you
support this thing that Trump said or
did
the details don't matter all every ques
every poll is really just do you like
Trump or not
because that's that's how people are
going to interpret it and they're going
to answer it along those lines
that's all
um and and so it shows the problem that
Trump will face in the general election
and I
I'm struggling to see how it's not an
insurmountable problem for him
that there everything is baked in who
can be persuaded at this point
is there anyone left of of all you know
all the potential voters in America
um in a general election
is there anyone left who's actually on
the fence about Donald Trump now I
totally believe that there are people
who could be swayed either way in the
primary there are tons of people I talk
to people all the time we're kind of
like I like DeSantis uh I also like some
of what Trump did I think you should get
a second shot I don't you know so
they're on the fence about it
um there's also been because of what's
Happening Trump now there's been this
rallying around him his numbers are
going up which is which is very
predictable that makes a lot of sense in
the Pro in the Republican primary
but these are all people who they're
going to vote for the Republican anyway
in the general
in the general election
in that context
who who can be persuaded
like is there anyone who would in a
theoretical general election between
um between Joe Biden and Donald Trump is
there anyone right now who's on the
fence I don't know I could go either I
mean I'm not sure I'm not sure I got I
still got to hear these guys out I gotta
hear Trump some out some more I might
vote for him I don't know but I might
vote for for Biden it doesn't exist
that's a category that doesn't exist
it's all baked in
there's no one left to persuade
and I I don't know how you get over that
I I I don't
no one has shown me how the math Works
how does Trump in a general election how
does he win what's the path to Victory
I'm I'm I'd be very interested to hear
someone explain that and I haven't seen
anyone explain it
and for me you know in the primaries
Ron DeSantis hasn't even jumped in yet
so
um and maybe I I think it's 90 chance he
will but maybe you know maybe he won't
assuming he does
and I I could talk about the reason I
like DeSantis it's his policies things
that he's done
um as Governor that that for me is why I
like him but I really could put all that
to the side
because in the primary
I am a single issue voter and I think
that we all should be in the primary a
single issue voter
and the single issue that matters in the
primary is who can win in the general
that's it that's the only thing that
matters
because all the rest of it is irrelevant
if the person can't actually win the
presidency
only thing that matters is who can win
now I don't have a crystal ball I can't
see into the future
um
but that's what I'm saying is that's
what we that's how we need to think
about this so when you're weighing the
candidates
you know you're looking at policies
you're looking at personality looking at
all those things but really you put that
to the side now you're running the math
in your head you're thinking most
plausible scenario who's more likely to
win the general and that's how we have
to make our
decisions
again for the daily y representatives
for the Bud Light brand owned by
Anheuser-Busch
confirmed a brand partnership with trans
identifying active activist Dylan
Mulvaney after followers speculated the
whole thing could be an April Fool's Day
prank
now if you by the way if you're one of
those people we talked uh you know a
couple days ago about Bud Light
sponsoring Dylan Mulvaney congratulating
him on his day 365 of Womanhood or
retina sorry girlhood because again this
is a grown adult man who is very
specifically pretending to be in an
underage adolescent girl
um so congratulating him in three of day
365 of quote-unquote girlhood we talked
about that and I saw even in the
comments there are people speculating
that well no this can't be this is this
is April Fool's prank this came out
around April fools it must be a big
prank from Dill Mulvaney I don't
okay this is this is still
the kind of coping that we have to put
to the side now we have to get past this
like if you're still in a position if
you still are
like it's hard for you to believe
that Bud Light would sponsor Dylan
Mulvaney
um that just shows me that you really
haven't been paying attention and you
need the clue into reality there is
there's nothing unbelievable about it at
all
and there's a lot of the same people who
who still insist that uh maybe this
whole deal of anything is all one big
prank by hand he's like he's Andy
Kaufman it's a perform performance
artist it's all one big troll
I mean this can't actually be serious
no it is serious
now it's not he's not actually a woman
obviously
but he is seriously trying to identify
as one he wants to be taken seriously as
a woman it's not a prank it's not a
anything like that
and yes we live in an occult in a
culture where the the major brands are
going to line up and uh they're going to
fall prostate to the ground and worship
at the feet of somebody like Dylan
Mulvaney that's where we live
a spokesperson for the company told Fox
News Anheuser-Busch works with hundreds
of influencers across Our Brands as one
of the many ways to authentically
connect with audiences across various
demographics and passion points
from time to time we produce unique
commemorative cans for fans and for
brand influencers like Dylan Mulvaney
these this commemorative can was a gift
to celebrate a personal Milestone and
it's not for sale to the General Public
so yes this was a real sponsorship
um as we should have always assumed
bulvinia has partnered with multiple
National brands for advertising
campaigns on social media including
KitchenAid kind snacks wedding dress
brand Asos uh
MAC cosmetics and others
this guy has he really has dozens of
corporate sponsorships
because again that's the kind of culture
we live in we should probably clue into
it by now
and we need to decide like when are we
as conservatives actually going to make
a concerted and real effort
to do something about this that we
complain about it we complain about the
fact that all these corporate brands are
spitting in our face all the time and uh
they're like going out of their way to
alienate their own customer base
and then some more cope we say oh go
whoa go broke no
I wish it was that way okay I wished it
was that way
where a company goes woke and then they
go broke that's not how it works
actually
in fact they go woke and they continue
making billions of dollars that's how
we're go woke make billions of dollars
we have the power we have the ability to
make some of these companies go broke we
could do that but we don't
that's what makes it frustrating
okay there is
strength in numbers
especially in a Marketplace
it's true that every major corporation
is woke they all are right
and so we can't realistically boycott
all of them
if we did that then you wouldn't even be
able to watch this show right now
because the phone you're using or the
laptop you're using to buy it on is made
by a woke company you bought it from a
woke company you're using a woke
company's uh you know internet service
provider
um you know
so
we boycott all of them and we basically
can't live in the modern world and we
also have no way to even organize any
kind of boycott like that because all
the all of the the mechanisms that we
use to more to uh to organize them are
also owned by by the woke
so yeah we can't boycott all of them
that's true
but we can pick some of them
okay this is something that we talked
about this on the backstage episode
um
on Monday
is something that the left is they're
very good at doing this
where they
they pick someone they pick a victim and
they make an example of them
okay they they pick somebody out
whether it's an individual or a company
that has offended them has crossed to
them and they say we're going to take
you down we're going to destroy you okay
you have become our personal project
not because you're the worst as far as
we're concerned but uh but just because
you're the one you're the one we've
chosen
and the left will do that and they'll
stay on it until they tear this
this victim down
now on the right we could do the same
kind of thing
and the only difference is that we're
choosing people and companies that
actually deserve it
and we'd be wielding this power for good
so yeah we can't make all the woke
companies go broke not not even close to
it but we could choose one company
that does something outrageous
to alienate and spit in the faces of
their own customer base
and we could say okay we've chosen you
and we're going to bankrupt you
because in reality there are millions
and millions of us and you do need us to
buy your product and if we don't you're
going to suffer
okay and you've got Mass layoffs in your
future uh and all the rest of it
we could do that but it takes it takes
uh organization
it takes follow through
it takes a certain you know sense of
kind of ruthlessness
because yeah if you do that you take a
company down you you know you you uh
affect their bottom line to that extent
remember people that work for the
company that aren't evil people they
just have jobs and they're going to lose
their jobs
now so you don't want to see that it's
unfortunate
but these are these are necessary
casualties
so we have to have the willingness the
willingness we have to have the
ruthlessness we have to have the
organization the attention span and the
follow-through
and on the right we have none of that
easily distracted we move from one thing
to the next
and anytime any one of us tries to say
let's focus on this issue let's focus on
this institution let's focus on this
thing right here and try to make
something happen you're then going to
have you know 50 000 people who are also
on the right come along and say why then
this is bad yeah sure you'll do that but
then these people over here are just as
bad so what's the point of even trying
we allow ourselves to get distracted by
these losers who have no interest in
winning don't know how to win and we've
got to stop doing that
all right let's get to the comment
section
[Applause]
baby game
tanjarisu says you missed the part where
after the man was accosted some woman
screamed get him kill him we're at War
whether you admitted or not
uh yeah I actually did miss that we
played the video on the show on Monday
of uh Chris Elston known as billboard
Chris on on Twitter and is that in his
activism he was he was at one of these
uh trans rallies wearing a a sign of
wearing a billboard that said children
can't consent to puberty blockers
because they can't and he was physically
assaulted by
um a a man identifying as a woman
and yeah there were people it wasn't
just the one trans guy it was there's
people in the crowd of course were
cheering it on you know get him kill him
and uh and they really mean it they do
okay they they they actually do want us
dead
um another tough reality
that has to sink in at a certain point
but as far as they're concerned as you
point out as far as they're concerned
they're at war with us have been for a
long time
crush is going to be a one-sided
uh Guthrie says this is actually a great
point you want reparations for slavery
but if it wasn't for slavery you
wouldn't be here in the first place and
you're absolutely better off being here
than anywhere remotely near the African
continent you can guarantee that
colonialism or not Africa would still
not be a nice and prosperous place to be
in fact just like India Africa is
probably better off for having been
touched by Europe in some way
um
yeah that's that's I I think it's
actually worth I played I think it's
about two minutes of the clip from
Dinesh D'Souza back in uh what was it
2002 on NPR I still can't quite get over
that fact on NPR
22 years ago 21 years ago uh you can
make this kind of point
defending
well no
talking about the the benefits of
colonialism
um
making arguments against reparations
saying things like the descendants of
slaves are better off being here you
know that's that was Dinesh D'Souza
laying that out on NPR only a couple of
decades ago that was the kind of thing
that you could say on NPR
um
but it's it's worth going if you can
Google that you can listen to his entire
uh you know his his whole statement on
this because it is it is very
interesting it makes a really good point
um
Michael Brown says way to bring it on
Home Matt with a fabulous fabulous
cancellation I think social media has
played a large role in this phenomenon
of good or bad think it's like people
have become a bunch of zombies who only
know how to hit thumbs or thumbs up or
thumbs down people seem to have fallen
under the spell of false dichotomy that
will now not allow their brain to have a
thought that is original or nuanced the
Perpetual insistence of scrolling
through bumper sticker slogans and the
erosion of the English language are all
contributing factors in this way of
thinking I love listening keep up the
great work uh that you do this episode's
definitely going on My Greatest Hits
list
uh
yeah it's the the inability it's not so
much
because it is interesting that you know
it's partly it seems like there's this
black and white thinking that people do
um
but it's not it's not so much that
because a lot of these same people they
they won't recognize good and evil in
the world in any other context they're
going to be talking about they want to
make everything a gray area well it's
impossible to say what's good and what's
bad
um
so it's really it's
the the problem as I said on Monday is
that
there's one thought there's one assigned
it's not even a position it's just one
thought one statement that's supposed to
apply to every issue
and sometimes the one assigned thought
or statement is correct so when it comes
to slavery the one assigned thought that
we've all been given that we're all
supposed to think and say is slavery is
bad
and that's correct it is bad
but the problem is that you're not
allowed to go beyond that that's the
only thing you're allowed to say about
it and if you say anything else about it
then you you have begun excusing it
which
um on top of the leading to ridiculous
policies like uh like reparations it
also just it makes us it contributes to
making us Dumber
so this this situation comes about
because we have become Dumber as a
culture and then it also feeds that it
makes us even make makes us all the more
dumb
because we're not allowed to have
interesting conversations you know
slavery given the fact that slavery was
a universal institution across the
entire world for thousands of years
there's like a lot that should be said
about it
um
it's just it's it's one of the
critical facts of human history
and so there's there's interesting
conversations we could have about
why was that how is it that
for thousands of years
almost everyone in the world
was basically okay with slavery
they might not have all owned slaves but
that would have been determined by
socioeconomic status
for thousands of years there really
wasn't anything like an abolition
movement anywhere
it was an accepted institution and and
now today uh we look at slavery and we
automatically recognize well of course
that's wrong
you know we recognize it as one of them
it's it's self-evidently wrong to us
and yet for thousands of years it was
that was not evident to almost anyone on
uh the planet
and that included
some of the most Brilliant Minds in
human history
though it's not nearly as simple I think
for a lot of people on the left they
would want to say well it's because
everyone who lived prior to everyone who
was born before the 60s the 1960s
basically was uh backwards drooling
primitive bigot
they're all a bunch of morons
but that's not the case at all I mean
some of the most brilliant these people
were in many cases again our IQ scores
are declining right now
so if anything evidence suggests they're
a lot smarter than us
and yet they they couldn't see
what to us is self-evident it's a very
interesting fact and I I don't have the
exact answer for it but uh it's
something we should probably talk about
but we can't because the only thing
we're allowed to say is that's bad
she could be argued with no great effort
that the main reason uh we are where we
are as a society is because we are
spiritually bankrupt when you have no
relationship with God you live a life in
chaos but as Ben Shapiro points out in
episode 13 of Exodus with Jordan
Peterson it's not just a one-way Street
God wants to have a relationship with us
as well check out the trailer the
romantic and tremendous yearning that
God has to be among his people is so
clear from from this language right he
specifically says it's not just I
brought you out to the Into the
Wilderness to serve me which is the
language of a king to his subject it's I
brought you out here to live with you to
dwell among you and it's repeated twice
in the sacrament section right I'm here
to I brought you out specifically so
that I can dwell among you he wants the
closeness with us he wants the romance
with us and that's why it's such a
tremendous sin against him when the
people end up essentially
throwing it out right I mean what
they're about to do with the golden calf
and the language that you'll see God's
response is okay well I'm withdrawing
from you in this episode of Exodus Ben
sits with uh Jordan and a Roundtable
group of esteemed Scholars theologians
and artists to discuss one of those most
seminal books in the Bible uh new
episodes are coming online every week
and they're all great exclusively for
daily wire Plus members but you have to
join now at dailywire.com subscribe to
watch Exodus do it now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we must
once again cancel the country of Canada
now it may seem a bit excessive I
acknowledge that every time someone in
Canada does something that annoys me I
respond by just canceling the whole
nation in most other cases I will simply
cancel the individual offender but
Canada gets treated differently
um they're on a very short leash with me
you know ever since they re-elected
Justin Trudeau again
um I realized that I have to adopt a
zero tolerance policy with the entire
country now if one Canadian does
something cancelable they all get
canceled but this is only fair
considering the Canadians in general
have allowed their country to slide
irrevocably into full-on left-wing Brave
New World tyranny and they've especially
surrendered themselves to the the LGBT
alphabet Mafia a similar process is
underway in the United States of course
but in Canada the process is complete
appeasement and worship of the LGBT
called is the country's number one
National priority which brings us to
this story from Global News quote
Ontario's NDP urged the government
Tuesday to create Community safety zones
that would protect drag artists and
lgbtq communities from harassment and
intimidation at their performances drag
performances have been targeted by
organized protests across the United
States but also here at home said
Kristen Wong Tam who is putting forward
a private member Bill to designate 100
meter zones around show venues Wong Tam
the ndp's critic on 2sl gptq uh issues
and who uses they them pronouns said
their bill bill is designed to keep the
community safe the bill would also allow
the Attorney General to temporarily
designate a addresses such as where a
show is taking place as Community safety
zones and anti-lgbtq harassment
intimidation and hate speech within 100
meters will be subject to a 25 000 fine
yes of course Kristen Wong Tam is
non-binary identifies as they them you
know eventually every politician in both
Canada and the United States will be
non-binary because it's the easiest
identity to tack on to your resume and
give you uh you know political clout
without having to make any changes or do
anything in particular to play the part
non-binary is such an utterly
meaningless label that the people who
claim it can't tell you what they mean
by it can't explain how or why they
decided that they have this identity and
cannot speak about it coherently for
even five seconds at a time Kristen Wong
Tam is I looked it up 52 years old
now I don't know when exactly she
discovered her inner non-binary identity
but I can already assume with absolute
confidence that it was very recently
she lived her entire adult life
in the binary until one day as a
middle-aged woman she decided that she's
actually some sort of mysterious human
entity who in ways she cannot possibly
explain actually exists outside of the
male female binary that has defined all
people who've ever lived since the dawn
of humanity
but she just like every other non-binary
quote-unquote person made this startling
discovery about herself like 10 seconds
ago
you know a whole bunch of leftists all
at once just recently at the same time
found out that they were non-binary
none of this was none of them were
saying this about themselves 10 years
ago for the for you know for most of
them not even five years ago
just now right now they've made this
determination
so it's almost like this is a fad you
know a social contagion and not an
actual legitimate category of being
almost
anyway here's Kristen they them
announcing her plan listen
this new legislation in Ontario is
designed to keep the 2s LGBT community
safe drag artists their audiences the
business and the facilities that host
those drag performances have been put at
risk and unless we put forward a
strategy to protect them Ontario's
social economic and cultural richness is
under attack we have to protect that the
proposed legislation does two things and
I will go through them firstly it
enables the Attorney General to create a
2s
lgbtqi plus Community safety zone to
prohibit within a hundred meters of the
property any homophobic transphobic Act
of intimidation threat offensive threats
offensive remarks protests disturbance
and distribution of hate propaganda
within the meaning of the criminal code
it also comes with it a penalty of
twenty five thousand dollars if
prosecuted successfully
secondly the ACT creates an Ontario 2s
lgbtqi plus safety advisory committee to
provide recommendations to the
provincial government on how to improve
safety for our community and to prevent
further hate
just a quick note here none of that is
true none of that is close to true there
isn't any Rising tide of hate crimes
against LGBT people especially not in
Canada of all places that's like saying
there's a rising tide of fat phobia at
Cracker Barrel just it doesn't make any
sense
but I do believe that there has
certainly been dramatic increases in
LGBT people reporting that they are
victims of hate crimes but the increase
in reporting is due almost entirely to
two things number one a lot of them just
fabricate hate crimes out of thin air uh
lie about it as we've seen time and time
again number two the category of hate
crime is increasingly being expanded
so that an LGBT person can claim to be a
hate crime uh victim the moment they
encounter any statement or opinion they
don't like
and this point is proven in that very
same clip when Christian they them tries
to prove that hate crimes are a major
problem by launching into a list of
cities where protests against drag queen
groomer events have taken place
so this is what she means by hate crime
any action or statement
taken by you know by anyone to oppose or
protest anything that any LGBT person is
doing
is a hate crime
and this includes I mean especially
includes anyone who protests the
sexualization of children by gay men in
dresses let's continue
firstly it enables the Attorney General
to create a 2s
lgbtqi plus Community safety zone to
prohibit within a hundred meters of the
property any homophobic transphobic Act
of intimidation threat offensive threats
offensive remarks protest disturbance
and distribution of hate propaganda
within the meaning of the criminal code
it also comes with it a penalty of
twenty five thousand dollars if
prosecuted successfully
now I can help you with that if you want
to prevent further hate what you could
do is leave the kids alone just leave
them alone
that's all you have to do but you refuse
to do it you refuse to stop you are
addicted to sexualizing children and you
can't stop
because almost all of the quote hate
that you're experiencing the hate you're
not you're the the hate that you're not
just making up anyway
is hatred directed at your actions your
behavior okay that's what we hate yes we
are
um if you are a leftist LGBT activist
or you are someone like Christian day
then
and you have picked up that there is
hatred being directed at you you're
right there is
but the hatred is directed at what you
are doing people hate what you are doing
specifically in this case they hate that
you are bringing kids into gay clubs so
that grown adult men can perform
burlesque routines for them
we hate that absolutely
this is the kind of hatred that
Christian day them is trying to protect
her quote Community from
later speaking of that Community later
in the press conference she brought one
of these poor oppressed groomers on
stage to tell his story
these threats and intimidation tactics
are very real and happening all around
us to people we love and care about even
in recent weeks I myself have been
victim to hate crimes and hate speech
I'm a professional drag queen who loves
what I do more than anything in the
entire world
drag is all about spreading love and
acceptance and allows people to feel
empowered and special
first of all why are they always dressed
like the evil stepmother from a Disney
film if the film is directed by Tim
Burton this is their idea of Womanhood
obviously and you also we can't skip
over the fact
that they have made drag queen into a
protected category
so drag queens can be victims of hate
crimes now
um which which includes like saying
something that I like so if you say
something to a dragon you are you are uh
you know committing a hate crime against
a protect Group which is I mean it's
literally the same thing as making
actors into protected groups
where if you if you do something an
actor doesn't like or even if you beat
up an actor well now you're not only
charged with assault but you're charged
with a hate crime because because they
are an actor
that's what the drag queen is
they and they don't deny that they are
acting they're playing the part of a
woman
which in and of itself becomes a
protected group
he did say something important there he
said that the drag you know drag is all
about making the drag artist feel
special and I don't doubt that for a
moment of course it's primarily about
giving gay cross-dressers an opportunity
to act out their sexual fetishes and
some of them as we've seen are
particularly excited about acting out
that those fetishes in front of children
but it's also about
feeling special that's the centerpiece
of the LGBT agenda it is to protect
their right to feel special
I mean as I explained during my talk
last night we live in the age of the
psychological man which means that
people Define themselves entirely by
their desires and their feelings and
their self-perceptions the self is an
amalgamation of an individual's desires
feelings urges perceptions and so on all
that matters is how the individual feels
and the most important human right is
the right to feel good to feel special
drag queens feel special when they
parade around looking like you know
cross-dressing Edward scissors
Scissorhands and so they have the right
to do that it is their most important
rights
and they say they have the right to do
it in front of children because it makes
them feel special
by this way of thinking nobody else has
the right to do or say anything that
would make the drag queen feel bad about
this Behavior
which is why they intend to throw Free
Speech entirely out the window and
criminalize protests against these drag
queen groomer events
that of course is the point of making a
safety zone The Zone doesn't protect
them physically because they were never
in any physical Danger instead it
protects their feelings
and their feelings are all that matter
to them
and they think all that should matter to
us
this is what the LGBT cult believes
and increasingly countries are writing
laws on the basis of this belief
Canada is not the only offender but it
is one of the worst
and that is why it is today once again
canceled
that'll do it for the show today we'll
talk to you tomorrow have a great day
Godspeed
[Music]
today on the Ben Shapiro show Donald
Trump is charged in Manhattan court with
34 counts of falsifying business
documents D.A Alvin Brad pretends this
is all about principle and Trump
launches a response from Mar-A-Lago
that's today in the Ben Shapiro show
give it a listen